[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift we've
got a great show for you a great cast of
characters as well among them these a
dog named Lucky who helped his owner
make a stunning discovery on the side of
the road what they find we will tell you
plus a veteran who found a unique way to
cope After experiencing disaster wall
deployed and a man who has explored the
world but it's what he's accomplished in
his personal life that is so inspiring
plus a physics Professor who uses her
own brand of fun to make science
enjoyable
for not just thousands but millions of
people
and a non-profit that acts as a fairy
godmother to girls on their way to prom
what's its Mission and hangs on a hanger
find out watch The Uplift
[Music]
hey there I'm Tony decopo this is the
show that lifts you up for the next 30
minutes you and me as well it's called
The Uplift for a reason and we are going
to begin with a professor who is making
physics fun inspiring her students in
her own classroom and also on social
media here's Jamie wax
Ready
set go the way Dr Tatiana yurokimova
sees it
physics is Real World Magic
and with a little training all right
next anyone can become a real world
magician will the potential drop
let's check
videos of her experiments have ignited
people's curiosity online racking up
tens of millions of views over the last
two years you cannot explain much in
this short clips but you can get people
interested
you again yes you can inspire you get
this part I will tell you as we filmed
our demonstrations and I never ever put
myself there I speak funny what's the
point people love the way you what's the
point no I never wanted to be in this in
this video students wrote the scenario
students were thinking how to explain it
students starting this video showing
these demonstrations she always wants
everything to be like a celebration of
science we met three of hirokimova's
former students two of whom work in the
world of physics today they all share a
special connection to the woman they
affectionately called Dr Tatiana you
walk into Dr Tatiana's classroom and you
can tell she wants you to be there and
not only that she wants to be there she
cares and she wants you to learn and
that makes you want to learn she never
makes you feel like you have to listen
you know like I know everything she
wants to hear everything that you have
to say so that way you can create
something together Dr Tatiana's Own
Story starts thousands of miles away
about six hours Northeast of Moscow
before the breakup of the Soviet Union
she was raised by two physicists and she
married you guessed it a physicist in
1999 she and her husband Alexei moved to
College Station Texas where they both
teach today was it just complete culture
shock or did you know you were home of
course I didn't feel home but you make
it home from inside just different
suppression over the last 20 years that
home has sounded a lot like this
when she isn't teaching
Dr Tatiana is doing Outreach
[Music]
blowing the minds of future scientists
unexpected and very excited you were
part of this study with 10 000 students
and physicists and people in sciences
and the result was that men are no
better acclimated
towards this than women over 10 years
there were no consistent difference
between a male and female performance on
these exams course I felt that this is a
very important message for my students
she's one of my role models students
like afia denani who came to a m after
seeing Dr Tatiana's videos watching Dr
Tatiana do the experiments online
especially since she was a female leader
it was more inspiring for me to even go
into physics my very first semester I
wasn't at class that morning and she she
looked at the people that were sitting
next to me she was like where is Cali
like you need to call her right now and
make sure that she's okay I just
overslept past my alarm I was like wow
like she knows when she notices when
you're not there what would you want
her to know about what she's done for
you everything that she did to push me
throughout my undergrad I've sort of
learned how to do that for myself so I
can be my own Advocate now because of
her what would you like to do that you
haven't done to start new programs
they're just not stuff so no
yeah I think she will start those new
programs Jamie Great Piece coming up
with prom on the horizon teenage girls
get help from a fairy godmother through
a non-profit called the glass slipper
what exactly do they do we will get into
it after the break plus our heartwing
videos there's one of them all of them
you've got to see stick around
[Music]
we have a heartwarming story for you now
coming from the Orange County Sheriff's
Office in Florida where Deputy Hal Davis
fulfilled a dream this month Davis was
temporarily paralyzed last year when a
tree limb fell on him he spent about a
year in physical therapy pretty intense
physical therapy in fact learning how to
walk again with one big goal in mind he
wanted to walk his daughter Hannah down
the aisle
Davis achieved his goal just earlier
this month there he is congratulations
to him all right to our next video 83
year old Ernie Taylor of Butler
Pennsylvania say hello to him if you see
him has an interesting support animal
it's a duck by the name of Gertrude
[Music]
Gertrude she of the Beethoven hair there
is a six-year-old crested P King not an
official support animal doesn't have the
paperwork don't ask to see it but she
does a lot with Ernie including going to
the store with him there she is there's
Ernie Ernie's family runs a duck and
Goose rescue they've got about 90
animals overall but Gertrude is special
and lives inside the house she often
goes viral on Instagram as well and I
mean for obvious reasons look at that
hair
all right Ernie well done okay like
Cinderella's fairy godmother there is a
non-profit called glass slipper and it's
swooping in to make sure students are
ready to go to the ball
or the prom the prom is also a good
option here's CBS Sacramento's Sakura
Gray
sparkly dresses and sky-high heels the
glass slipper is a non-profit stepping
in as a fairy godmother before prom
they're making sure girls who were in or
are in the foster care system have a
chance to feel glamorous we want them to
feel like they are VIP and they're
coming into the most beautiful salon and
getting their hair and their makeup and
jewelry we want them to feel like they
are royalty and they can choose whatever
dress they want and it's for that 100
volunteer driven relying solely on
donations co-director Jennifer Kidwell
says the community stepped up bringing
this Boutique shopping experience to
life for us it was let's bring an
amazing experience to them where they
can shop for everything things that
maybe they couldn't otherwise afford or
have as a selection for them and they'd
be able to take everything for free
kidwell's mother founded the glass
slipper back in 1997. the two now get to
see the organization impact together I
just really want these kids to know that
the community just supports and cares
about their future I want them to have
an experience that will be an amazing
shopping experience but that the
underlying message of that is that they
are beautiful they have intrinsic value
and that they have the potential to just
change their world volunteers making
sure these girls have their Cinderella
moment after all it's the little things
and the shiny ones that can make a
difference
Nifty line there and a great story all
right coming up in just a moment a
Massachusetts man and his dog make a
lucky discovery on the side of the road
what was it we will tell you plus an
Afghanistan veteran who lost his leg and
then experienced PTSD from what he saw
over there while he's found a unique way
to cope thanks to an organization right
here in the U.S
[Music]
we introduced an ad to a veteran who
lost his leg and then developed PTSD all
after a tragic incident in Afghanistan
serving this country but he found a
special way to cope back here in the U.S
here's CBS New York's John Diaz with
that story
feel comfortable it's my safe zone for
someone who knows danger as well as Army
veteran Alfredo de los Santos finding
that level of protection is a blessing
finding it in art is a gift it's a
natural high whenever I feel like I'm
losing my mind
this is what helped me everything you
see here is what is nightmares you know
frustrations
body parts things that emotionally been
bothering me to understand his pain you
have to know his backstory in 2008 while
on deployment the army Sergeant stared
death in the face I was in garage in
Afghanistan and we're going to an ambush
I was in a in a vehicle I was the Gunner
and it blew up that tragic incident led
to many complications hearing loss head
trauma PTSD and the loss of his leg he
spent two months placed in a medically
induced coma and two years in the
hospital and that's pretty much what I
had to learn how to be a human being all
over again I had to learn how to walk
how to talk it wasn't easy you can
imagine what I was going through I was
medicated all the time I was suicidal
but this Brave veteran will tell you the
recovery process got better when it led
him to Semper Fi and America's fund a
non-profit that provides lifetime
support to Injured service members you
guys helped them get to the Finish Line
right definitely definitely Janine Canty
is a senior director at the fund she
says in almost 20 years the Nationwide
organization has helped more than 29
thousand veterans cutting through the
red tape they provide services so vets
can get the tools they need right away
to start their new normal often
there are expand expenses that can't be
covered by you know the military even if
they're on travel orders so we can fill
in the gaps the fund provided enough
money for alfredo to get a hand cycle
which he now uses to compete
professionally but it's the art
materials and tools the fund pays for
which truly helps them decompress and
has turned him into an advocate for art
therapy when I'm doing this it's like I
don't think about the pain there's no
pain it's a way to control the demons
they're still hunting me helping to turn
the nightmares into Knights of ease for
him and anyone going through the same
battles I was afraid to ask for help
you know don't be afraid to ask for help
all right John nice piece to our next
story while walking his dog a dog named
Lucky a Massachusetts man happened upon
well
a little bit of luck here's CBS Boston's
Julie Mcdonald with the story
to know the newest member of his family
but after only a few weeks the dog's
sweet name suits him come on Lucky
they're still working out their new
route and routine making last week's
walk so surprising without him I
wouldn't have gone down there so
that's why we're calling them lucky
strolling down Rollins Street a big pile
of cash caught Rick's eye I saw it on
the side of the road I thought it was
Monopoly money the cash is about eight
thousand dollars and their checks made
it up to 12. so that's a good amount of
money you know Rick joked with his wife
about taking a trip to Encore but that's
just not the kind of neighbor that he is
he dropped off buddy and came straight
to Groveland police who were delighted
by the good deed it made their day they
said because
a lot of people might not have done that
I don't know I was I'm hoping that this
shows people that that's what you're
supposed to do turns out the money had
flown off a neighbor's car on their way
to the bank it was returned to that
grateful small business owner who later
stopped by Rick's house to shake his
hand and say a sincere thank you well
yeah I always feel like I have my own
integrity and that's the one thing they
can't take away from you I would hope
that somebody would do that for me
oh not only lucky for him but lucky for
the small business owner that is quite a
gesture well done all right coming up an
explorer who has been to the furthest
corners of this planet the highest
mountain tops you name it and when
tragedy struck he did not let it prevent
him from doing the thing he loves
to be able to
go back to a place that has been such a
important part of my life
to see it again when I thought I would
never do anything again for me
feels like the right thing to do
[Music]
Eric Larson has been to the North Pole
the South Pole and Mount Everest all in
the same year that would be one 365 day
stretch but it's the mountain he
conquered in his personal life that
makes him the most inspiring here's
David begno
Eric Larson is packing for a trip he
never thought he'd make a journey to the
North Pole
it's not the destination that he assumed
Was Out Of Reach he's been to the North
Pole six times already
[Music]
what's incredible is that he's able to
travel again at all
you see back in 2021 the 51 year old
Larson was diagnosed with colon cancer
he says the doctors told him it was
terminal here in that news
and trying to think about
what those few years would be like with
my family and my young kids was to say
it was difficult is is the extreme
understatement
but the prognosis was wrong the cancer
was survivable though the treatment was
debilitating six rounds of chemotherapy
radiation and 14 inches of his colon
removed what was
your lowest point during the cancer
I mean
how much time do you have there there
are so many low points when I had
surgery to remove the cancerous area of
my colon
I had a very difficult recovery I was on
oxycodone I was in bed I couldn't sleep
and I would
wake up in the middle of night and just
try to walk around the room I could
barely get out of bed it was so much
pain
Larson always had a major advantage on
most people because years of Adventure
taught him how to survive in the
harshest conditions
he is after all one of the world's
leading polar explorers in 2006 he and a
partner did the first ever summer
expedition to the North Pole in 2010 he
became the first person to Journey to
the North Pole the South Pole and Mount
Everest in the same year long day cold
wind I think with the wind chill was
close to 60 below how many times have
you almost died doing this I've fallen
through the ice I've been stalked by
polar bears I've been in a lot of very
precarious situations over the years and
you get a little bit of a Gallows humor
with that you know in the sense like oh
that was close
let's just keep going
the cancer is what grounded him one of
the chemo drugs diminished what he calls
his superpower the ability to withstand
cold opening the refrigerator to put in
a glass of cool water to my lips and
have intense pins and needles
instantly impact whatever area that coal
was touching
was debilitating and and I live in a
cold environment too so it's not just
about opening the refrigerator but it's
going outside like actually getting to
the chemo treatment was a major obstacle
still though he never lost his passion
for Polar exploration
even though he calls it one of the most
boring Sports what is it about going to
the extreme that really does it for you
what I do is just part of who I am I
don't stop to I don't wake up in the
morning and say oh why am I going to do
this I just do it and so it's just how I
was built what makes it boring though
you're traveling across a big vast white
nothingness oftentimes you know I've
spent days and weeks in conditions where
the visibility is like being on the
inside of a ping pong ball you can't
even see the Horizon but now he's
looking clear across that Horizon back
to Adventure and back to the North Pole
I get the notion of doing this before
you have cancer
but after you survive cancer
why put your body through that again
that's a good question
um and it's one that I'm wrestling with
quite honestly I don't like being away
from my family as much anymore but
to be able to
go back to a place that has been such a
important part of my life
to see it again when I thought I would
never do anything again for me it feels
like the right thing to do this time
he's headed to the North Pole as a guide
to show others what most of us will
never get to experience
you see we can't all relate to his
record-setting life
but we can relate to pain
and
Newfound perspective I'm talking to a
man who set out to explore some of the
far-flung places of the Earth but am I
also looking at a man who's still
searching to find himself
yeah yeah yeah you know I used to go on
these trips and I thought if I could do
the hardest thing for as long as I could
I would have an epiphany where it all
came clear that I would know everything
and what I've realized is that's never
going to happen I'm still looking for
the answers
that I know I'll never find
but the search has value
and the effort has value in my mind and
coming back has value
there's a picture that's worth the
journey if the answers are out there I
think David begno will find them always
nice to have him playing cleanup here
that's the end of our show I hope it
brightened your day and lifted you up
I'm confident it did if for some reason
it didn't reruns are free I'm gonna go
find some more good news see you next
time
thank you